[APPLAUSE]
TROY SKINNER: Hello, everyone.
My name's Troy Skinner.
Thanks for coming today.
I work in immersive,
where we created
self-determination theory,
which is the leading science
framework worldwide for
understanding motivation
and behavior.
Our founding group, which you
can tell by these numbers,
is very old.
It has over 350 published papers
and 100 plus years of combined
experience in applied work.
Our model is used or referenced
more than 30,000 times
per year.
Other academics use it.
There's research
across tons of domain.
So if you ever need
some bedtime reading,
there's lots of information
to find on the net
after this talk.
And then where I focus
is on a unique practice
at the intersection of
software and motivation,
consulting on 50 plus
app projects a year.
Essentially, what we go
in is talk to developers,
talk about design,
throw out ways
to increase engagement by
using good behavioral science
practices.
Attention that you see a lot of
times in design conversations
is between business objectives.
You're trying to focus on
bringing down churn, raising
subscriptions, very
laudable goals that
are important to our businesses,
and being customer first, which
obviously is an aspiration
if you care about who
uses your applications.
And this is very
natural tension.
But we found in our work
that it doesn't have to be.
Exciting news coming out
of our decades of research
is that, when you really
focus on satisfying consumers'
fundamental basic
psychological needs,
it increases their value
for the application.
And that increased value shows
up in all the outcome metrics
are important to our businesses.
You see reduced churn.
You see greater engagement.
You see greater monetization.
Kind of where we
fit in the picture
is obviously we've gotten very
good as an industry at building
applications.
Lots of them are in the world.
We've gotten very good at
collecting behavioral data.
So we know if there's
good outcomes in our apps
or bad outcomes in our apps.
But where there's
kind of a black box
is in the middle about why
people do what they do.
So what we do at
Immersive is we really
focus on understanding why
people do the things they
do with in applications,
not only understanding it,
but measuring it
with really concrete,
discrete, granular metrics.
And then helping
use that information
to make better design decisions
about how to improve apps.
Self-determination
theory is, again,
focused on fundamental
human psychology.
So kind of the underpinning
to that is that every human--
all of us have
one in this room--
has three basic fundamental
psychological needs, which I'll
get into in more detail later.
But we also look at things
like intrinsic versus extrinsic
motivation, goals and motives,
which are essential to long
term engagement,
mindfulness, vitality. .
It's a robust comprehensive
model motivation.
So it has a lot of different
nooks and crannies,
not all of which
we'll get into today.
Also, because it's about
fundamental human motivation,
it travels to a lot
of different contexts.
I do a lot of work in
entertainment software.
We work with world
class athletic programs
to avoid athlete burnout.
We work in education.
We work in retirement.
Because it's about humans,
it's not trapped in any domain.
So it works across
all applications
because, if humans use it,
then motivation applies.
So now let's actually
get to the topic at hand.
Something that you
see a lot when people
talk about motivation
is that more is better,
that we want to essentially
get people to act by jamming
them full of motivation.
You've kind of seen
this humorous picture,
that if you have an exercise
app and your plan is
to have everyone
chased by a t-rex,
you'd certainly get
lots of running.
But that probably wouldn't
lead to long term engagement
once the terror subsided.
The right way to
think about motivation
is not that you want more.
It's about what the quality
of that motivation is.
So quality of motivation is
more important than quantity
of motivation, which kind
of brings us to a continuum
that I'll lay out
here for you guys.
Essentially, if you look at--
we can measure these things.
If you look at what people
are experiencing in your app,
there's basically low
motivation that ranges from,
they don't care, through,
feeling external pressure
to engage in the app.
Internal pressure, which
means I feel like I should do
and I feel guilt
or shame to do it.
Or personal value,
which means I have
a good reason, a
strong rationale,
for engaging the app.
To intrinsic value, which
is like, I just love running
or I just love using this app.
These are all different
categories of motivation.
And they lead to very
different outcomes.
On the kind of bottom, you see
that low quality motivation
leads to less engagement, lower
productivity, less learning,
everything that we care about.
And in contrast, high motivation
leads to great outcomes.
So why is this useful?
Well, what we do is we measure
individual users, the quality
of their motivation.
And it allows us to
basically customize
our content to meet consumers
where they are motivationally.
So if someone has low
quality motivation,
they don't really have a good
rationale for using your app,
then some of your
strategies might
be to essentially
communicate to them where
they might find more personal
value in the application.
If, in contrast,
someone is already
in love with the
application, you
don't need to convince
them to use it.
Instead, you continue
to empower what's
driving that intrinsic
value, showing them increased
opportunities, essentially,
and also avoiding
undermining that
motivation by being very
mechanistic in your design.
And I'll kind of explain
what that means more.
So now let's get
into the theory.
There are three basic
psychological needs.
Needs is the
important word here.
They're not want in the
same way that hunger
is a physiological need.
So somewhere in the room
might say, sorry, Troy.
I don't believe in hunger.
I'm not a hunger guy.
It doesn't matter if you
believe in it or not.
If you don't eat,
you'll starve to death.
Same thing with
psychological needs.
If these aren't fulfilled,
then you essentially
starve psychologically.
It works across cultures,
across genders, across ages.
It fundamentally works for
everybody in the same way
that hunger does.
So what are these needs?
The first one's autonomy.
This is our need to feel like
we're the author of our life,
of our experience.
We're the one
driving the action.
The opposite of
autonomy is feeling
controlled or manipulated by
someone or an application.
What you want to think about
during development when
trying to design for
increased autonomy is,
first, focus on
features that help users
build a personal narrative of
value for your application.
Essentially, the way to
think about it is you're
always trying to get people
to form long term goals,
not take actions based upon
very short term motivations.
The underpinning of
long term goal formation
is, why am I doing this?
What's my rationale?
How will this help me?
How will this aid me?
So that communication has
to be enormously clear.
The opposite of
that is essentially
a carrots and sticks
approach, which
is something you want to avoid.
This is things like rewards,
badges, time pressure,
those kinds of things to
get people to take actions.
It's not that rewards
can't be an important part
of motivation.
But they have to be
subordinate to people
having a personal narrative.
If there's something
they want to accomplish
and they take meaningful
steps towards that
and you reward them,
that's awesome.
If they don't have
that personal narrative
and essentially you're
trying to generate actions
all through carrots
and sticks, that's
going to lead to short term
improvement in behavior
but mid-term and
long-term problems.
And so it's important which
foundation you're building on.
The last thing is,
when possible, you
want to provide meaningful
choices about how
to interact with the app
like what value they get out
of things because, essentially,
if people get choices,
then obviously it's easier for
them to endorse the path around
because they're helping to
design with their experiences.
The second need is our
need for relatedness.
This is our need to meaningfully
connect with other people,
to feel like they matter
to us, we matter to them.
Things to think about
during development--
there's lots of mistakes that
happen in kind of social realm
around relatedness
is that it's not
about-- it's kind of like
the more is not better.
It's not about how
many connections
you have on LinkedIn.
It's about the quality
of the relationships
that you have with people
within the application.
So what you want to catalyze
is meaningful support.
Where you see real improvement
in metrics and behavior
is when people feel like
they matter to one another.
So it's how do you build
those relationships,
allow people to meaningfully
support one another,
do things like collaborate
together on a shared project,
have shared goals, coordinate.
Mentorship relationships
are a big deal.
If someone's expert
in a topic, can they
help someone that's less expert?
That's meaningful
to both parties.
Those are the kinds
of relationships
you're trying to bring about.
Another thing that's very
common in app development
is you see that people will
take an action in the app.
And it will get shared out
to their social network.
It's not always the best policy.
Once we worked on a
exercise and weight loss
app that had the brilliant
idea that every time you
gained weight to
tell everyone you've
ever met that you just ate
a lot of food in Berlin.
Not really the
best communication
for your social identity.
There's kind of this
automatic assumption
that any sharing is good.
But you always have
to think about it
from the sharer's perspective.
Everything you say is
not necessarily something
they want out there, which
brings us to the last thing--
What people are
fundamentally trying
to do in most applications
is create a social identity
that basically
celebrates what they're
good at, what makes
them different,
essentially what's
distinct about them.
Those are the messages
they want delivered.
I don't want people to know
that I gained five pounds.
I want people to know that I got
to give a talk at Google Play.
These are exciting things.
So you really want to identify
what narrative people are
trying to write that has social
impact and kind of communicate
that for them.
The last need, which is often
the easiest to understand,
is our need for competence.
This is our desire
to be effective,
to be masterful, to grow.
It tends to be very
intuitive to everyone
that works in development
because, obviously,
if your app is not accessible,
people can't use it,
then obviously they
fail at high rates.
So during development,
one of the things
that we see people have
the most trouble with
is when giving feedback
to users as it's
important to be informational
rather than judgmental.
So let's say that I am
picking up an exercise app.
And I instantly
don't know how to do
a push up, which is likely.
Then, if you essentially
flash a big red light and say,
you have failed a
push up, that makes
me feel incompetent
and not really want
to stick with the exercise.
In contrast, if I get
informational feedback
about how to do it
better, then I grow.
Then you're on the right
side of motivation.
So a lot of times we
do things accidentally.
We're trying to be clear
in telling people what's
happening in the application.
But accidentally,
we essentially judge
their lack of effectiveness.
And that basically
undermines motivation.
So if it's informative
and they grow, good news.
Judgemental, it's bad news.
The next thing is that you
want to provide scaffolding
for successful growth
throughout the lifetime
of your application.
So what we're going to talk
about more is that, when you
have a huge consumer
base, people
come in with different
degrees of expertise.
And then as they
engage in your app,
obviously, they're building
experience over time
and becoming more
and more competent.
So if you know that,
fundamentally, people
need to grow or they're
going to quit an experience,
then you have to
realize that you
need to meet each
person where they are,
both from an
expertise standpoint
and from an
experience standpoint,
at the point that they
really need information.
So you have to be really
contextual about understanding
what's important to people
progressing and kind of given
that information
when they need it.
The last thing is
is because growth
is so instrumental to
people having investment
in an application, part of
your communication strategy,
the way in which you want
to talk about your app,
both in app and time when
just talking to people,
is you want to kind
of foreshadow for them
paths for growth
and how they can
continue to develop the
longer they stay with the app.
That's essentially where people
get a lot of value from things.
So that's essentially a
key part of your messaging
and communication.
So fulfillment of these needs
is essential in applications
because they're
essential in life.
This is not a model that's
talking about app development.
It's a model that's talking
about what leads to fulfilling
enriched satisfied consumers.
So when your application
leverages these truths
about motivation, then
you get lots of benefits
to all the things that you
care about as a business
long term engagement,
et cetera, et cetera.
So that's the general framework.
A lot of times it's
easier to understand this
when we go from a general
conversation to specific.
So I'm going to talk
about some of the apps
that we've worked with
recently and kind of put
a little more meat
on these bones.
So an important topic
that's a huge issue
for behavioral
scientists is retirement.
I don't know-- it's
basically everyone
understands how important
it is to lifelong happiness
to prepare for retirement.
But in the states,
only 4 out of 10 people
are actually saving
enough money.
So 60% of the population
is not prepared.
So a huge behavioral
science problem
because it's something
that you have
to do for the benefit of
people and for the country,
but no one really
wants to engage in it.
Why don't they want
to engage in it?
Well, the first thing is that,
unlike games and entertainment
apps, saving money is
not inherently fun.
Very few people
on a Friday night,
when they're reviewing all the
options of enjoyable things
they can do, think, now's the
time for retirement planning.
So when you work as a behavioral
scientist on this problem,
the first thing
is that anyone you
talk to doesn't want to
talk about the topic, which
obviously is a challenge.
When we start looking
at retirement apps,
we ran into another problem.
All retirement app
start with what
we would basically characterize
as terrifying math questions.
So they basically ask
you these two things.
They first say, when
do you plan to retire?
And the second thing they
say is, how long will you
stay in retirement?
When you look at that closely,
what it really basically
boils down to is, when
are you planning to die?
So if you wanted to
demotivate people,
that's essentially the
perfect construction
because not only do
people not know the answer
to those questions but it makes
them feel an existential crisis
that they don't know the answer
and that death is impending.
So retirement
apps, if their goal
is to terrify their
customers, they're
really on top of things.
And horribly, that is their
goal because, essentially,
their model for how
to increase retirement
is to scare people,
to essentially make
them feel that, if
they don't do this,
then horrible things
will happen to them.
If you remember what
we talked about earlier
about motivational
quality, that's
what we call external pressure,
where you're basically
trying to get actions
by scaring people.
Instead what we
want to do is make
people realize what
the benefit for them
of preparing for retirement is.
So we had a different view
than the traditional retirement
industry.
So how did we approach this?
First, we wanted
to flip the script
and basically talk to
the people using the app
and say it's not about math.
It's about creating a
foundation for living
the life that you love.
One of the big
disconnects that people
have when they think
about retirement is they
don't realize that
the person they're
going to be in 10, 20,
30 years when they retire
is the same person they are now.
So where we wanted to start
the conversation is basically,
what do you love in life?
If you had more
time, more money,
how would you spend
that time and money?
What are your passions?
What do you care about?
This is diametrically opposed
to, when do you plan to die?
It's essentially saying,
why do you want to live?
What do you care about?
So that's where we started
the application script.
The second thing is, once
we got people really fixed
on that point, we want to
make them more effective
at answering the
questions we needed
them to answer to figure
out what the right plan was
for them.
So we made the
language less jargon-y.
We made it more colloquial.
Tied the questions
back to the plan
that they had already started
to make when they discussed what
they cared about their lives.
And it put things in a much
more comfortable way for them
to kind of intelligently
answer those questions.
One of the things that you find
when you take this approach
is that people feel much
more support and caring
from the application
in the company
because it's not trying
to terrify them anymore.
It's basically trying
to support them and help
them plan for retirement.
So relatedness scores
shot up immediately.
When we worked with our
client, they came to us.
So they obviously felt some
appeal for this approach.
But then we started to say,
this is what our plan is,
they were kind of nervous
because their experience,
over dozens of years of
working in this field,
was the longer you made the
application process, the more
people that quit along the way.
And essentially,
asking people what
they wanted to do with their
lives lengthened the process.
And so even though
they believed in it,
they were nervous
about its success.
Happily, what we
saw when we finished
the application is that
retirement savings were
increased by more than 400%
versus the previous design.
And as I mentioned
previously, customer loyalty
and appreciation soared
because now people
felt supported in the
process of figuring out
retirement rather than scared.
Another area that
we worked in a lot
is health and fitness,
health and fitness
also very challenging.
Maybe not as hard as
retirement, which is
the worst, but also very hard.
One of the things we talked
about earlier that where
we sit in the relationship
with developers
is there are a lot of
behaviors that you see.
And the real question is, why
is someone doing that thing?
Exercise is massive for this.
If you go to a gym,
you see 100 people.
They're all working out.
So behaviorally, they
all look like they're
doing the activity
that you want,
that they're all
successfully exercising.
But what's under
the surface is very
important to the prediction
model for how long
they continue to exercise.
So the question is, what
can we do with our framework
to help find where each
user is and help them
along their journey
to a healthier life?
So the first thing
we want to do is
you want to measure
and understand
where the customer
is at motivationally.
And I'm going to click through
a number of statements, which
basically characterize different
kinds of motivational quality.
So someone might be
exercising because they
were told they need
to make changes
or they're going to die.
This is close to
our retirement thing
again, where, if
you don't do this,
horrible things will happen.
The next one is, I know I
should focus on my health.
I'll feel guilty if I don't.
I know it's the
right thing to do.
Not necessarily that I want
to do it but I should do it.
The next statement is, I
want to take care of myself
because I know it will
benefit my quality of life.
And the last one
is, I just enjoy
having a healthy lifestyle.
Basically, each of these
are a different step
along the way to higher
motivational quality.
And what we know, by doing these
studies 100 different times,
is that where you
are in this journey
is predictive of how long you're
going to continue to exercise.
Essentially, the first
statements that I read
have very bad results.
That's where you hear people
like-- the stat's like only 5%
of people that start an exercise
program continue with it
for more than eight weeks.
On the far right, you
see great outcomes.
These are the people
that run every day,
have happy healthy lives.
And so the question is, what
do you do about this problem
because tons of the people
that come into applications
or come into gyms sit in the
unhealthy space motivational.
And so as behavioral
scientists, they
care about people's well-being.
Can we do anything?
So first, we understand
where they're at.
The next thing we
do is, if we know
they're in a place
motivationally that's
not predictive of them
continuing on with exercise,
then we know that we have
to help them internalize
greater value for the activity.
That means giving them
the right content that
supports their competence,
communicates to them
the long term value, essentially
tries to make an argument
experiencially about what
the benefits of exercise
are going to be because we know
we have to essentially move
them within the application to
a different place motivationally
or they're not going
to stay around.
I mentioned this earlier.
I actually gave you a push
up example, so it's perfect.
Finally, you want to
avoid signals that
evoke evaluation or pressure.
It like a pretty
fit room in here.
But some of you may
have experienced
not exercising for
two or three years
and trying to get back into it.
What that feels like
is you oftentimes
feel like a novice coming
back to an experience
that you don't
feel expert around.
If you're in a gym, you're in
an exercise app, oftentimes,
the assumption is you already
know everything about exercise.
You know the right form.
You know how many to do.
You know everything about it.
Obviously, that makes people
feel like they lack competence.
So then, when they
take their first baby
steps into doing
something and basically
an application or a trainer
says wrong, wrong, wrong,
that's not how you do
it, but obviously, that's
a barrier for people
to continue on.
So again, this is where
you don't want feedback
to be judgmental.
You want it to be informational.
And oftentimes,
judgmental feedback
happens in very subtle ways.
I kind of mentioned
this earlier where
we'll do things that
have strong heuristic
value like flash a red light
to say that your form's wrong.
But essentially,
what someone's seeing
that's in a fragile state
around their competence is,
I'm doing this wrong.
And I'm horrible at exercise.
And what's the point?
I should eat potato chips.
Instead, what they need
at that point is support.
And so really, what
this approach is about
is recognizing where
people are motivational
and being sensitive to
meet them at the place
that they're at to
try to move them
to a healthier place
around exercise.
The last thing I
want to talk about
is a workshop that
my partner Scott
did with Calm, which,
some of you may know,
is an excellent meditation app.
And basically, this is a lot of
what our work looks like where
we sat down with them.
Understood their product.
And kind of brainstormed
some future possibilities
for the application.
The first thing, there is a lot
of ideas that came out of that.
Someone at Scott's workshop
said, my head's bursting.
There's so many things that came
up with this model and place.
But some of the things
that were most important
was, one, let's try
to replace a one size
fits all onboarding
approach with content
that matches the specific
motivational profile
of each customer.
You can kind of see on
the mock on the right kind
of some suggestions for a
way, a more tailored approach,
might be more
appealing to people
coming into an application.
Instead of just
saying, let's meditate,
would you like to meditate
to reduce anxiety,
to improve your focus, to work
on sleep issues, et cetera,
et cetera?
You can see how that
would make someone
feel more authorship, more
ownership, feel more effective,
be able to find the
content they want.
It's essentially the thing that
we talked about earlier, which
is tailoring things to people's
more specific growth interests.
The next thing is we
measure motivational quality
when we work with developers.
And so, within the
realm of meditation,
it made perfect sense to say,
the point we're trying to make
is, if you meditate, you
see all these great outcomes
to your physical health
and psychological health.
So why don't we take
those measurements
that we're doing for
development purposes
and show them to the consumers?
Show them that, once they put
in the work in their practice,
that they're getting all these
obvious benefits that they
care about their lives.
That's a lot of the reason why
people come to meditation apps.
So that was an exciting
idea that everyone kind of
grabbed onto.
And then lastly,
that same detail
that we use to show people
that this is working also
shows us where our
program is not working
as well as we would like it to.
So it might be that we have
these eight different domains.
And three of them,
every one that
essentially tries to reduce
anxiety gets perfect results.
And we've crushed it.
It might be that,
in three others,
it works for some people.
And it doesn't work
for other peoples.
And it might be in the
last two that it's not
working for anyone.
This allows us, as developers,
to pinpoint where we most need
to add design features.
And then we can start
to triage, well,
why aren't these two
sections working well?
Is it that people
don't understand it?
Are they ineffective?
Do they not
understand the value?
Are they not seeing
the benefits?
Is there not good feedback?
All the issues that
we brought up before.
So essentially, the
point of these metrics
is to give us more precision
about why people are doing what
they're doing in applications.
So just a few takeaways
that hopefully you
got from today's talk.
One is that you
can build loyalty
by authentically
supporting your customers'
basic psychological needs,
which are autonomy, relatedness,
and competence.
I've been in literally, over the
last 10, 15 years, 5,000 design
discussions.
And I understand how oftentimes
you're triaging a problem.
And a lot of times
you want to find
any solution that will work.
Taking shortcuts
is the wrong term.
But you oftentimes get really
myopic about how to solve
a problem. , Really what our
recommendation is just take
a step back and try to
understand the foundations
of consumer behavior
and motivation and say,
how do we solve this design
problem with that kind
of greater perspective, because
that's essentially what's going
to give you the best
long term results.
Next thing is that
reframing the app experience
in the context of these needs
deepens motivational quality
and builds personal
value that lasts.
Really, it's a
variation the same point
that I made before,
that there is basically
ways to design things that are
much better suited to setting
up long term engagement.
A lot of times, we make
choices as designers that might
solve a problem temporarily.
But this is really the
foundation that lasts.
The third thing is collecting
motivational profiles,
things like motivational
quality and how
the three basic psychological
needs are being fulfilled
empowers customization of
the user experience at scale.
Oftentimes, what you'll find is
there are three or four or five
profiles of consumers that you
can find in your application.
And you can make intelligent
choices about which ones
to serve first, how to serve
each one of them, that ends up
getting you really good
benefits in consumer engagement
very quickly.
Fourth, remember the negative
effects of external controls
on autonomy, even when
building rewards systems.
A lot of app design has
ties back to game design.
People realized very quickly
that reward systems, badges,
experience points
levels, all these things
are an important
part of game design.
And there's a way in
which those things
can be employed
effectively in applications
that support people's
narrative about the experience.
But a lot of times, when
those things get divorced
and it's all badges, rewards,
levels, and no understanding
of what's driving people's long
term engagement of the product,
it essentially has
an undermining effect
on motivation and engagement.
So you don't want to build
your app's engagement
on a foundation of sand.
You really want to connect the
thing that's going to last.
Lastly, as behavioral scientists
that care about autonomy,
we want to be
autonomous supportive.
We wouldn't want you to see
this framework as rules.
It's supposed to be guidelines
to kind of inspire innovation,
help you to think more
creatively about how
your application can
improve its engagement.
So that's hopefully the
spirit that has taken in.
If you need any help figuring
out what questions to ask,
how to collect
this kind of data,
how to design more
motivationally,
please contact us at Immersive.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]